I don't hear anything so there's no
audio
like Dr Seuss she says he's a bad guy
yeah well Dr Seuss was mean to a lot of
people conversation with the preschooler
I work with not that hard to explain
racism to kids to understand Dr Seuss is
a bad guy well sometimes people are mean
to others without reason when they're
different than them it's not very nice
it's not okay who is Dr Seuss mean to he
was mean to people who looked different
to him and people who believe different
things than he did
ironic like Donald Trump
yeah wow so this comment was put on a
video that had absolutely nothing to do
with politics but let's dive in because
teaching is political the education
system the curriculum School zoning
funding standardized testing all of
these things can create and further lead
to class and racial inequalities and
impact life chances for our students
especially as a history teacher my
students deserve somebody who's going to
confront and challenge the injustices
and untruths that are in our history
that have led to discrimination so yeah
you hear this lady
she wants to harp on problems of the
past it's it's her job to shove her
world view down their throats and give
her the [ __ ] are you on one of you
exactly as you're saying she wants to
give her opinion she doesn't want to
teach facts she wants to teach her
opinion this is how most teachers are I
literally just went to school went to
[ __ ] high school I can speak
firsthand they're all they're like this
they shove this [ __ ] down it wasn't like
this when I was in school it's [ __ ]
man yes teaching is political because as
we develop curriculum and have
conversations with our students equity
and anti-racism need to be in the
forefronts of our minds as well as
giving our kids the means to gather
factual information and form their own
opinion oh yeah but this is oh yeah
she's teaching them to form their own
opinion and if they disagree with her
they get shitty grades yeah they're
racist get the [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of here
wildly different than indoctrination or
propaganda because I'm not trying to
sway my students opinions I want them to
form their own educated opinions what
I'm doing is challenging a broken system
and hopefully laying the groundwork for
progress and justice I'm so glad I'm not
in her class
smug summer camp and we had our award
ceremony tonight and
I got misgendered
and they presented my award
and I know they didn't do it on purpose
oh this person just sounds dull doesn't
make it hurt any less it hurts that much
going in the bathroom and crying okay
I'm really sorry
didn't do it on purpose but
that means that I've been here for two
months
and still
there's some contests stuff like so
weird
let me tell you stories so when I was
nine years old adult baby he does look
like an adult baby yeah yeah good point
when I was mine
um I went to my I always had really long
hair and my mother was really mean and
she just gank it to brush it the base
grandma Yeah base grandma was mean she
was just right and I would just be like
I cry every night after a shower when
she would do my hair so I was like I'm
just not short hair so nine years old I
go to this place called disco hair it
was really cool there was disco balls
and loud music anyway they gave me like
a very short like little boy I looked
like a boy my hair was like kind of like
yours so I had this really short haircut
I was done with the base Grandma torture
but then I went to um Burger King drive
through with my sister and I was in the
back seat and we get him and her friend
was working at the drive-through and her
friend sticks her head out and goes oh
my God is that your little brother and I
was nine years old so I started to cry
because I was like oh no I look like a
boy oh my God I didn't know the word
misgendered
I was just sad because I was a little
girl you're also nine years old it was
nine nine years old and I cried right I
mean so after that
um I had I made sure to never leave the
house without earrings and I always had
earrings on and there was never any
confusion ever again and it was fine but
it was nine nine years old I cried and
so she ran back in and she got me a
shake and extra fries for free and I
stopped crying so it was pretty easy you
know you were nine I was nine once again
not give me a give me a milkshake oh
yeah I'm happy now this is a grown ass
woman it's a grown baby woman a woman
baby I feel so bad for her that she is
so mentally and emotionally friendly she
needs to listen to something it's it's
actually really sad and I can't even
make fun of this Carl because I'm just
feeling like you're really sorry how is
she gonna get through she can't even get
through being misgendered at Day Camp
Awards I just made the comparison of how
like when the Tates reacted to us
Tristan was like yep she has a nice son
he's in shape uh looks 21 22. good
looking woman looks great for her age
she has kids who are obviously 21 22
years of age she hasn't got green hair
it's like what's the what's the real
difference dude like he's just saying
something else people call you the wrong
[ __ ] all the time how are you gonna let
every little thing affect your life
these people want you weak and
controlled by your emotions that's what
that's their main goal all they talk
about is feelings everything you say how
does that make them this person feel
because they want you we so the book I'm
reading right now
um what did I say the name of it was
irreversible damage is about the the
trend of transgenderism in in mostly
it's it's actually mostly in teenage
girls and I didn't know that it's far
more teenage girls transitioning than it
is teenage boys and so what what basic
of it is a teenage girl is just she's
got pimples her hair's funny her Skin's
greasy you know her body's awkward she's
getting she's either got boobs and it's
getting weird attention from grown men
that she never got before she has no
boobs and feels like left out of of
growing up like it's just a shitty time
I was there it's a weird awkward puberty
puberty's [ __ ] awkward that's what it
is so what's happening is they're not
going down these rabbit holes of people
like this and they're finding a way to
escape being a teenage girl by turning
into this amorphous creature of
non-gender or saying they're going to be
a boy but still really being a girl in
every possible way except for the way
they dress but they now can take on an
identity of being having this cool edgy
thing instead of growing up and growing
through it and these people out there
are feeding into it and giving them a
quote unquote community and they're all
they're coming out on the other end of
it and so many of them who went through
double mastectomies which they're doing
to 15 year 14 to 18 year old girls
cutting their boobs off and they're
doing all this hormone therapy they're
coming out the other end of it and going
oh my [ __ ] God I'm I'm not a crazy
teenager anymore what have I done what
have I done and because these people are
out here convincing them that that's
where they belong what was the name of
that stuff again someone asked
irreversible damage dope it's really
good
it's really hard yeah it's really hard
I'm so sorry it's considered an
unpopular opinion but if you have a
daughter you need to stop calling her
princess
the way that does how did you used to
wake me up every day
that means good morning Prince in
Italian you know that really scarred me
you're pretty racist sexist and
homophobic for that should I have said
would you feel better
you should have used the plural oh man
oh because the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you didn't know if I was a boy or a
girlfriend of the princess is based on
her beauty as her most important asset
no it's not it's based on her [ __ ]
power to cut people's heads off that
needs to be skewed by a man and it
doesn't focus on their own what are you
basically based off of Mario you know it
it needs to be saved by a Mario if you
call it the princess so first of all
[ __ ] you tired somebody call me a
princess yes and it and it girls want to
be princesses when they're little they
like tiaras and [ __ ] right
right just to be able to I'm gonna have
a pretty dress and a white horse and a
tiara and that's funny but you know what
else you could teach her you could say
you're a princess you know what you're
in line for the throne here's let me
like you can possibly roll one day you
can you can talk about anything you can
you can teach them that there are other
sides to being a princess besides just
being pretty but what's wrong with
teaching your child to want to be a lady
yeah it is an unpopular opinion in this
house weirdo so you know how like
there's bass things with nature so a
baby automatically knows like when you
throw them in water they just know to
float like put their put their back on
there's things that you naturally know
as like how the dog knows when you get
something to naturally bury it where to
go find it there's things that you just
naturally do you know how when kids are
little girls naturally like to just go
for dolls and stuff and they want to be
princesses because you know women
naturally want to be caregivers they
have that maternal Instinct and you also
just want to be treated like a princess
and then as Society continually digs
into your head and tries to strip that
away from you and say that you know
that's not what you're meant to be
you're supposed to have a career that's
what's going to make you happy doing all
this [ __ ] it's I don't know they
just twist everything but if you look at
like nature and what these people are
naturally these kids naturally want to
do just makes more sense I don't know
maybe I butchered that but I feel like
you guys understand what I'm saying just
let it play out I also have another let
it play out don't make it so heavy to be
a two-year-old I also have another
theory you know how little kids are
afraid of like monsters under their bed
and stuff I think that's because for
thousands of years growing up you had to
be afraid of predators and stuff so
that's still like instilled in our DNA
to be afraid of some Predator coming
after you so you think it's there's like
a monster coming after you they sort of
talked about that on The Joe Rogan
podcast and then I had that little
spin-off but I think that would I think
that's a valid take why don't we call
girls scientists engineer doctor like
why does it have to be something
be like oh princess what do you need
like No my daughter's father called her
princess yesterday and I had to lecture
him again because we do not use that
term in this house even my own sisters
have called her princess he's gonna move
out if he hasn't already maybe I come
across as very controlling but I think
it's a very maybe I come across and she
shouldn't
term mostly I feel feminine or
non-binary today I'm feeling really fun
and cat-like as well yeah
but um I also feel masculine mostly
boyish
um what do you mean I don't ever really
no calm down this is sad yeah this is
sad
um I'm feeling kind of proud to have a
uh but
um for crazy person also you know
sometimes want to take these guys off
but other times I'm happy to have them I
love to play with them oh I love them
imagine going through life like this if
I eat a bag of chips and I get brain fog
I feel like I'm [ __ ] imagine going
through your whole life living like this
I hate having my brain clogged it just
makes me sad this is actually sad it is
I can't I can't get upset with the part
where I get upset is that there are
little teenage girls feeling lonely and
and separated from the world because
their little click of friends they're
being twatty because that's what teenage
girls do and then they go they go and
they get caught in this world and this
is a place for them to feel like they
can be special that's what angers me
like this person belongs in an asylum
yeah it's sad dude other days I want to
tape them down
um I'm running out of time but yeah it's
I go through stages of you just provided
some crazy value thank you feminine
non-binary and sometimes boyish so
that's I just added bug to my list of
pronouns so here is a very quick
tutorial on how to use bug bugs pronouns
in sentences who does she look like she
looks like a cartoon character getting
up with my friend moth later uh bug just
dyed bug's hair and it's a super cool
green color right now I think we're
gonna go to bug's house and play some
video games and then I think bugs said
that bug wanted to go to the store by
bug Cell It's just sad so I don't even
know what to say and then maybe we'll
get to hang another time I love hanging
out with moth what's the saying it's
hard to win a debate against a smart
person but it's impossible to win a
debate against a stupid person yeah
stupid slash crazy crazy person like
this is just what am I even what do you
want what do I say to this you know what
I mean like is a super cool friend and
I'm so glad that bug hangs out with me
I what I'm learning what is some of the
things how many questions
um that is how you use bug bugs
bug self pronouns uh and I'm always
willing to answer questions about my
pronouns no thank you I have no
questions there already doesn't just
affect women
one of the things that I that I'm
learning in this book there are a lot of
examples of real life people who are
teenagers who are transitioning
transitioned or detransitioning and one
of the things in the morning is that a
lot of times the parents in the
beginning were like that's just a phase
whatever or like they didn't realize
that the kid was going down this Rabbit
Hole until it was too late and then they
tried to get the kid help but the kid
went to a therapist where the therapist
said well hey oh you you want to
transition your gender now okay let's
talk about that let's explore that let's
talk about the medical procedures you
can get so parents are actually trying
to help because a lot of times I think
this is all the parents fault and you
know what it's not this is just kids
just wanting to escape the general pain
of puberty and some parents are trying
to help their kids to not make mistakes
that are going to [ __ ] up their lives
forever like young girls getting full
hysterectomies where their uterus their
ovaries are and their Fallopian tubes
are taken out so they basically go
through menopause in their teens and
then they can never ever have children
and quite frankly you know most women
are you know who are just straight and
want to have a traditional family aren't
doing that until they're mid to mid 20s
to mid 30s so at 14 15 16 17 you can't
be making those lifelong decisions this
isn't even all parents fault I'm just
learning this whole other perspective
that I think you guys should read this
book I have no skin in the game for the
book other than I'm fascinated right now
by what I'm learning in it
let's see what this nut has to say
period already doesn't just affect women
two Spirits trans men non-binary people
and genderqueer people can all have
periods and arguably period poverty may
be higher in these populations here's
why you've ever seen a tampon dispenser
a box of free tampons in a men's
bathroom what about a period aisle not
labeled feminine hygiene or pink boxes
all around it periods Perry's tough and
dangerous time for people that aren't
cisgender women so if you're donating
period products or putting them in your
workplace or School make sure they're in
all bathrooms no I'm not doing that I'm
not doing that
[Music]
trust me I'm not mentally ill it's just
that I've been
overthinking all the time
[Music]